Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Outlast 2
Now we're about to attempt to cross this lake on this raft
and I say "attempt" because whenever I try to do something in this game,
it never seems to work properly
And I have a funny feeling
Ohhh noooo
I actually have to control this which means
I have to avoid some dastardly things
And somehow... Oh no
I can't rr- I can't row
and record at the same time I just gotta look- with my eyes
So now's the time when supernatural things
Will behest me or I will die a horrible-
What was that?
Oh no you can't fool me, I saw something
peeking around that corner!
Oh, I saw something... Oh no
Oh no.. Oh, of course-
Stephen King's "The Fog"
has rolled in. Great!
Just carry me off into the underworld if I'm not there already.
I'm crossing the river Styx to have a negotiation with Hades
Oh no (We get it Mark) XD
Oh No
Ohhh
Yeah okay!
*return of the sousaphone guy*
Oh! Ok
Alright then!
OH! Fucking Hell!
Great I don't what that was
Hi
What the fuck is that?!
And what was that? Was that a hand or was that a stick?
Oh God, oh seaweed!
Ahh gross- oh no. All the fish are dead
Blake:  "These are signs. The apocalypse"
Blake: "I hope to god I'm just losing my shit."
Ugh
Yeah they kind of are the signs but
again -- ayyheyyy!
Ok  yeah I didn't want to dip a toe into this thing
and suddenly it's going all wrong... Oh boy, hi!
Hello
Oh HI
Yeah get to your boat, get to your boat, get to your boat, get to your god damn boat
*markiplier noises*
Huurgh, HUUUGH
NO!! STOP!
Get off of me!
I'll kick you in your many hands, ya pecatoncary piece of shi-aat!
Go go go! You're right there, c'mon! Right there,
come on! A little farther!
Dig deep! Breathe!
*more markiplier noises*
Alright, we made it.
Frickin frick! Everything wants to kill me
at every goddamn turn!
You'd think at some point I would just embrace death.
Like, I-I've gotta be on my deathbed, right?
I've got frickin' infested wounds all over my body.
but also in my hands
I've got a broken coccyx, which means
I broke my ass many moons ago,
and my wife has the -- the frickin,
Anti-christ in her belly!
Unless these are all
psychic things influenced by whatever the hell
that bright shining light and loud noise are.
The Reapers are influencing us, if you're wondering.
But there's gotta be...
some reason, right? There's gotta be a reason.
Am I going to the rapids or am I...
am I just kinda being stupid in going this way?
I've a funny feeling that I'm being stupid because that's a pretty safe bet in this adventure, but
at least I have the common goddamn sense to know when
NOT to go forward!
I'd just run the heck out of there!
...Except that would make me seem like an asshole
because I'm leaving my wife behind. So this guy's kinda brave for doing all that.
I guess I would.
I guess I'd keep going. But-but I'd be pissed about it!
I'd be PISSED!
'Cause this is a non-stop stream of bullshit, it shouldn't be happening here.
Shouldn't be happening.
I'm not happy. Not happy camper (?)
Oh hello.
Hiiii.
Okay.
*random noise*
ow!
*Blake rambles* Hey, how about you just hop off there?
*Blake continues being loud*
Ah-
Hi- Hellooo!
Yeah, I know.
Come ON!
FUUUUCK! Come on! Yeah, there you go.
What the hell were they?
Were those the heretics or were those again in my mind
like I think all of this is?
Uhhh, boy.
Ohhhh!
So it WAS the heretics!
Yeah ok. Alright.
I guess i'm.. Going for the-
long haul.
*Mark laughs, repeats what Blake said*
Oh, man.
Okay.
How do YOU know there's no baby?
I dunno, how do I know there's no baby?
Maybe there's a baby, and maybe there's not, but what the hell is going on over there?!
They look like they're having a FUN TIME!
Woah, hi.
Aoohhh-kay?
Why'd you bother lighting it on fire
if you were just gonna d--oohhhhh nooo.
Oh-hoh noooo. Ohh.
Oh that's a lot of dead bodies. Oh that's a
lot of dead bodies. Oh this is
a LOT of dead bodies. How many people?
Okay? I just wanna know. How many people?
Maybe give me a number here. How many people were in this frickin
hellhole of New Ezekiel or
whatever they called it, I mean New Ezekiel was Papa Knoth, but
how many people? Huh?
How many people?
I wish could record some of this, but I can't have my camera up
at the same time, I gotta paddle
with BOTH HANDS! I could grab onto ledges with
both hands and hold the camera, but NO!
Can't paddle and do that!
At least here maybe I can let the current take me because I bet I --
I should've documented that whole *gibberish*
that place over there.
Uohh, I don't think I can go upstream, I just realized
I probably could've stopped and let that -- Cuz the current is
just kinda carrying me at this point.
Euurgh.
Yeah, it is.
Oh well. Too late.
Can't do it. Yeah, I'm sorry I'm missing some of these footages,
I really am, I wanna get them all! But it's just...
It's like set up to make you go through it again if you
want all of the -- Oh owww. OH!
*gurgling noises*
Okay, alright then.
Ohhhh... This is gonna suck.
Oh, nevermind! I'm pleasantly surprised.
That turned out better than expected.
It was my ONE POSSESSION!
Please still be there? What do you mean "please still be there?"
Well, just ride a log, ya goober.
Do you really need a RAFT?
Like a big dumb doof.
That's what I thought, ya big dumb doof!
Alright, what have we got...
Hey!
STAY OFF MY RAFT! Ooh.
Ughh.
Alrighty then! Gonna go this way and hope nothing BAAAAAD happens!
Yup, nothing bad happening!
Nothing b-- oh, hi.
Okay, alright then, hello! Who are you?
Alright, goodbye then!
Motherfuh -- motherfucking no?
Oh, that. Oh, THAT. Ughhh.
Ughhhh.
Ughhh.
Ughhh
UGHHHHH
UGHHH UGHH
Oh boy. Yeah, I probably... let me just, uh...
Oh my God, I missed THREE?!
THREE?!
Ah, that's ridiculous!
Ughh.
Yeah, one of the two. Yeah, it couldn't be anything else.
We're -- oh really? We're all welcomed eventually?
Where? Where is this big welcoming party happening?
Ohh boy-oh
Ohh boy -- hi. Uh, it's all so squiggly.
Ugghhhh, so gross!
Ok. So I don't need to go down there...
Don't need to go over here
Someone was eating something... There's gotta be a way to get back to my raft.
Push this? Maybe? Oh, I can!
Hey, I finally get something right!
Oh, I'm so strong with my bloody hands!
Crash.
Alrighty then.
Shoopty. Alright.
La la la la, I am balancer [?]
Hope no locusts come and get me...
But that is interesting though, you know?
That is interesting that it is
literally the signs of the biblical apocalypse:
the plague of locusts, y'know, the fish dying in the river,
like that's...
that's literally, y'know...
"Love set us free," yeah that's good song lyrics, but
it makes me think that none of this is real.
or at least, not all of it is real. Like, these people are
still here and they are really into this shit.
But as far as everything else...
What is and isn't real is the biggest question in
my mind about this game -- Hi. Oh, I thought you were something.
Right?
Good job.
oh, hello.... Hi
H'okay. Go that way please.
Like...
There's no other way around it. It's just like...
Everything can't be real here, it can't just all be a coincidence
that this is all happening like this
It's not magic!
I refuse to believe that it's magic!
Therefore there must be some reasoning behind all of this.
And either way, I'm gonna get to the bottom of this, but
Maybe it is connected to the first in some way,
because there was a lot of scientific bullhonky going in
at that asylum in the original Outlast.
I mean, even in the Whistleblower DLC,
they were all working for a very specially focused secretive facility
Maybe
What the fuck was that?
I see you!
I see you all!
I'm watching you! Oh, I'm watching you alright.
Oh, I'm watching you.
Maybe... maybe all of this is like
some sort of experiment, right?
It's all an experiment, right?
Oh, you're not quite walking right there.
But it's all an experiment.
Or it could be.
Like -- it's plausible. It's plausible that there's some sort of
scientific operation happening here...
and that's why...
That's why this town exists next to some big
shining bright light loud honking horn
Ohhhhh, great.
I've got very little raft left.
Was that supposed to happen or was I just an idiot?
Okay, I think that was supposed to happen.
Okay. Wow, I'm still going. I'm a trooper!
I'm a trooper, even if I was to lose all my limbs,
I'd probably still be crawling on the ground towards Lynn.
And that's love right there. And love sets us free.
Indeed it do, indeed it do.
But not Papa Knoth's love.
That's... that's no good.
Here we go.
Well, there's a bridge!
There's the mine, yeah. Oh! It's a home mining town.
Well I don't know. So maybe those were  smoke stacks.
That's...
Well that's... alright.
So why were you... were you just working together because it was a job
and you had nothing...
That's sad. Okay, that brings a sad dynamic into this
that I didn't need amongst all the DEATH and the TERROR and ehhth
You know, all that death stuff -- okay, never mind then.
Hi.  Ohhh, hi.
Ooohhhh
What do I do about that?!
HI
What do I do?
OOOOHH HI.
Where did you all come from?!
Why are you all here?
Where am I going?
OH where did you come from?
OHH where'd you come from?
Ok. That's weird.
That is weird.
HEY!
OKAY
Maybe I should sta -- ohhhhh.
Heyyyyy, fucking--!
What do I do?
Where am I?
Hi - oh, no.
NO (x10)
Ugh...
Maybe I should have turned around and ran.
Maybe turning around and running would have been a good idea.
For some reason I wanted to see him...
...lick me.
Oh, I'm running.
Shoop!  Okay, still there.  Alright, running running running.
I think.  I hope I'm running.
I don't know if I'm running.
Kinda like speed-walking through the water.
EUGH
Ohhh nooo.
Oh no.  So now, HERE I can totally see --
Oh, this is bad. I can totally see -- can I climb up this?
Please tell me I can. Yes I can. Okay.
Ah.
Okay.
I could totally see how that would correlate to reality.
I'm swimming in the lake...
and I'm getting to a destination, like I can totally see
how this is actually all just correlations to reality here.
Uh, what's in here... This one's dimly lit, so I'm just trusting it.
Oh boy. Yeah, RIP those open! Yup, okay.
Is there something in here that I should know about?
Oh-kaaaay, alrighty then.
Ugh, why?  Don't do that to me.
There's got to be something else here.
Am I supposed to go in the  -- oh no.
I don't know if I should trust that!
My prodigious brain doth says that's bad.
Oh, hi.
Yeah!  I think I need to call a janitor!
That's, uh -- well THERE'S your problem!
It's, uh, it's shooting BLOOD out of it.
Oh boy.  Alrighty then. What does this say, if anything?
NOTHING.
Absolutely dick-doodly.
I wonder if anyone else, if they were looking at the gospel.
What'd it say?
*creepy whispers in the static*
Okay? Alright then. Who's in here?
Huh?
I'm not afraid of you.
Ah. Oh. Ah. Okay. Alright then. Oh good.
Ah. Well, THERE'S your problem, ma'am!
Oh boy. That's actually really well done fluid physics!
I haven't mentioned yet, but this game looks fantastic.
Like, I didn't even need to say it. It just
plain old DOES look fantastic.
BLARLARARAARGHH
And I mean, I hardly say that anymore these days
because graphics have gotten to the point where like, yeah!
They're supposed to -- ooohhh God.
Oh, oh okay.
oh, shit.
Girl:  HE'S COMING!
Mark:  HIIIIIII, FFFFFFFF --
Girl:  *continues screaming*
*displeased Mark sounds*
MYAIM
Alrighty then, you be like that, you -- is it getting darker?
Alrighty then.
Please, oh come on, I -- where am I supposed to go?
Am I supposed to go to the other one now?
Ugh, frick you.
That one actually got me good, that caught my air in my throat.
Which is not good.
Not good at all.
Oh, you're open now!
Oh good.  And apparently 'HE' is coming?
I'm assuming you mean that, uh...
...priest that I suspect.
Okay, that's jammed.
Oh yes, please do that more.
That makes me feel good in my brain.
It doesn't make my eyes hurt in the least.  Yeah, no, great.
Locked.
Why, why, WHERE?
WHERE FROM?  WHERE FROM, WHERE GO?
Oh, THERE!  There from, there go!
UGHH!
Alrighty then, what do I do?
What do I do? (x3)  Why do I do it?
In here?  This looks -- NO, THAT'S THE WRONG THING.
Alrighty then, in here?
Boop, oh hi!  Okay!
I doooooo--!
What do I do?
What do I do?  In here?
OKAY NO?
What do I do?
Okay. Fine, we're fine! He's just a bit of a DOUCHE.
In here, maybe? Hello?
Alrighty then.
I'll play your game for now, but I don't wanna play it for a while.
Play a game on all these computers, maybe.
Ah, here we go.
Oh. Noowww,
...Falling, is, worse, than, living.
Uoohhh, no.
Oh, no.
Oh no.
This poor kid!
And how did I --
How did I relate to all of this?
Where did I fit in to all this, because
obviously I'm with
Lynn. And I'm dedicated to Lynn, and I'm here
rescuing Lynn, but Jessica is just
on my mind.
And we were obviously all friends in high school...
OOOOHHHH
Well, THERE'S your problem, ma'am!
Uuuuugh!
Alrighty then, I'll just coast -- I'll just -- oooookay.
*girl he's chasing is screaming in the background the whole time*
Ohhh no.
Ohhh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Alright, here we go then.
*girl is pleading to be left alone*
Well, alright then, that was fun.
Glad we did that.
*Mark shuddering*
Now here's the -- I'mma throw this out as just a crazy theory
maybe all of this, this whole town, is just in his mind,
but I don't think that's true, I think this town
a hundred percent exists. I do.
Why is it red outside?
Why is it red outside? Do I even wanna know?
Is the blood moon out? Are you gonna have to go all
Bloodborne on this shit? Oh God, it's raining blood?
It's legitimately RAINING BLOOD.
Is it? Is it literally raining blood?
Is that what's happening right now?
I'd like to think not.
Okay, yeah, let's consult this one.
Let's think about this.
Ugggggh -- *blows light raspberry*
Okay, yeah, okay. Jeezums.
I don't know WHAT is going on here.
I don't know HOW any of this is happening.
Is this some sort of, like..?
What was that Jim Carrey movie?  The Truman Show!
Is this The Truman Show?
Is that what's going on here maybe?
Because...I don't know if that would make anything better
but at least it would have an explanation for it, because
WOW, why is it raining blood?
Why is all of this happening?
Maybe the Antichrist really IS there.
In my wife's belly!
Apparently, I have to do something about it. I don't know.
Is that going to be the choice at the end of this?
What is that?
Oh, it's a lightbulb.  Gosh, I thought it was...
...some kind of fly over my head.
Alright.  Well, I found the mine.
Oh, I got an achievement!  'Golgotha'!
I wish I knew what THAT meant.
Pretty sure that's a--
*interrupted by whispers in-game*
What did you say to me?
No, I -- someone whispered.
Someone whispered here.
Okay.
But either way, it's bizarre. Like, the whole
place was split into two straight factions
because -- woah.
Because
What Val wrote about the dreams...
she was having dreams because she regretted
having to kill her baby...
She didn't have to, but y'know, with Papa Knoth...
Lot of things shouldn't happen that do.
But uh, yeah.
Not recording-worthy, though.
Not recording-worthy.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, oh my GOD!
Wha -- Whaaaat the fuck?
Uh.... okay?
Okayyyyy....?
Alrighty then.
So someone just locked me in here, right?
*whispers*  Okay.
Everybody be quiet up there.
Because we're down below here.
Okay. Maybe ignorance is bliss and I don't need to hear everything around here.
Oh hi. Thank you, I needed to read this.
Are you dead? Okay. Imma judge by the flies
that you're actually dead. Ohhh boy, another chapter!
(reads note)
Again, I don't know what any of that means.
And why does this guy have this?  Are these re-writings?
Or is this just what this guy is coming up with off the top of his head?
Cuz' uh, I don't know which is true right now
and apparently I am alone here, so I'm just gonna
HUUUUH-OHHHKAY
Alright then!
Sorry to disturb your bucket o' hands there.
And feet, I see that.
But uh, I don't like being here and I don't want to be here longer than I have to.
So if I could just carry on and be on my way,
I'll be a happy guy, and you all can go
fuck off and die.
Uoohhh.
Okay, I feel the same things you're feeling, dude,
but you don't need to be such a whiny baby about it.
...Hide? Yeah, just in case you're TOO SCARED!
OOHH little baby want his diaper?
Wuhhh!
Uh-oh.
So something is up there...
...waiting for me...
So um, uh
uhhhh
Why?
Ohhh, don't do that to me.
There was definitely something up here!
There was 100% something up here!
I'm just gonna go. I'm gonna go (x4)
UHHHHHH! I'm gonna go!
OOOOOH, I'mgonnago!
Okay?  I'm gonna go! (x2)
I'm gonna go and I'm gonna be fine.
*chains rattling*
I heard that.
SOMETHING was through here!
Euuugh, something was through here!
Okay!
Aww, I don't like that!
Blaugh, I'm using up all my batteries right now.
Saved it for this one moment of truth here.
OHHhhh don't do that to me...
Do not...
Do that...
to ME!
I FUCKING TOLD YOU!
OKAYTHANKYOUIGUESS?
I guess we're on the same side maybe...
I don't THINK we are...
Where'd you go?
Oh he's gonna die, like, INSTANTANEOUSLY
uuuugh, still raining blood out there...
God, these guess just need to stop jumping out...
And scaring me!
with their JUMPSCARES!
*huuugh, frick*
Now where am I going, through here?
Yeah, seems like a good idea,
"Point-of-no-return" style.
now to watch this guy die...
*squeakiplier* I AM GETTING LITTLE BIT SICK AND TIRED
OF YOUR ATTITUDE HERE GAME!
I've had it up to HERE
At least it's bright and sunshine-y out, huh?
...or is it just a light in the hallway...?
...it's not actually sunshine-y-
IT'S NOT it's just *incoherrent babbling*
it's just a bright light...
Okay, so, why are we HERE?
hello?
Why'd you do that?
You just changed.
You just changed on me!
Why'd you do that...?
ohhh, unlocked are we?
It's quiet in the library...
I wonder how long THAT'S gonna last...
Probably not very long...
*door lock clicks*
Oh thank you!
THANK YOU!
THANK YOU! I WAS...
I was hoping I wouldn't have to do that myself!
It's only polite!
Can't even go through there...
hello...?
oh I don't like this, I don't like this..
I missed anything?
No, thankfully, I haven't missed anything.
But I'm going to if I keep overlooking things in here
Can't wait for good tidbits to re-GAAAARD!
don'tdothattome...
don't do that to me...
don't do that to me!
...don't do that to me...
hello...?
You just be nice to me. Please.
That's all I'm asking game!
Oh good, one of these is online.
It's what I've always wanted!
Oh no...
What? Blake *chuckling* against the machine.
Oh...
I don- I a- NO!
I-
YOU KNOW WHAT? I'M NOT GONNA DO THAAAAT
Why is there a run option?
*Squeakiplier* I'M NOT-
You know, I'm not gonna do that...
There's something directly behind me isn't there?
OH fucking god...
I EXPECTED something...
...and I still got scared by it
You son of a bitch
You sack of shit!
You sack of piece of ass and
and blast you
TO HELL YOU STUPID BAAAAASS-
-TURD!
This game is getting me.
This game is getting me...
and I don't like it.
I'm using up all my batteries, but hey! I got one, good.
Good for me.
I gotta keep moving.
This is obviously not gonna be very nice to me.
Oh here we go!
Hello!
Oh, so this was Jessica's computer.
*snort*  BlakeAgainstTheMachine.
The ONLY friend.
Uohh.
Oh!  *starts reading messages*
*continues reading messages*
What?
*reading*  He also says make your own luck.
Wait.  'Sometimes he raises a hand, but I don't feel like I have control.'
*continues reading verbatim*
WHAT?
Ohhhh.
Oh yeah, THAT'S WEIRD. I should've been recording that, huh?
Oh, that's bizarre, huh?
Hmm, a little weird!
Is it some kind of Morse code, maybe?
There's like, something on the screen to --
Nope, it's just BLANK.
OH COME ON!
Fricking frick, are you serious?
If I don't get this, I'm gonna be very pissed!
I'm gonna be PEEEEEEVED-DUH.
So that was the other thing that was on her screen, by the way.
alright, fine.
What good is that gonna do me?  It's  just gonna be garbled.
Man, they're putting secrets in here. People are gonna have to
piece these together afterwards.
-- together, they're gonna have to do it!
Right, but this opened up I think. Don't think this was open before.
Ay yi yi yi yi yi yi yi yi yi yi --
- YI YI YI YIYI.
Ok, not that way. Huurgggh, alright.
Okaaaaaaay.
*moar Squeakiplier*  Maaaahdedub, I don't know about THAT one.
I don't, buhhhI'm not okay with that.
Fine. Be like that, you GAME.
MWEEEUGH.
You wanna be like that, huh?
Be like that?
I'm not insane, right?  This door opened up for me.
Like a DOUCHE.
Like a DOUCHEY douche.
like a dum-dum douchey...
Jessica: "Watchful savior,"
Jessica: "Wash away all that I've been wrong today"
Jessica: "Help me every day to be gentle, gentle, more like thee."
Jessica: "Always near and dear to thee."
Oh no.  Oh no, the corruption is following her.
Yeah, the corruption just follows her everywhere.
So weird.  It's messed up, it's messed up
because I think we all understand what's happening here
or what happened in the past, anyway.
I just don't know why it's being brought up NOW.
Like obviously, this psychosis that it inhibits --
-- er, 'inhibits'.   Like,
INFLICTS on everyone here, it,
it dredges up the past, it makes them remember
their 'sin'.
Or something like that.  Or maybe the sin is manifest
in a way that feels like God's punishment
if they are religious, and I don't know what that means
if they're not.
'Help me'. Pretty sure that's what that means.
I just don't know.
I wonder how many Easter eggs are through this game?
Cuz' there's gotta be...
There's gotta be just TONS of them.
You know what I mean?
There's gotta be like -- if you were listening with your microphone
in certain areas of the game, do they like..?
Does it shift and morph, and give you different options or answers?
What does it do?
Y'know?
Oh hi.
Hello. Hi Jessica -- how you doing?
I'm not gonna go over there just yet, because that seems like a trap and I don't wanna...
...deal with that.
Oh hi.  Good!  Oh, it's a miracle!
*quiet, uncomfortable noise*
What have you got there? Oh, snake with an apple, okay.
Alright.
Alrighty then, I guess I'm gonna go this way.
Ohhhhh! Waaaiiiit a minute.
Wait, is there a name tag here?
Wait.
WAIT.
You guys are seeing what I'm seeing, right?
Is that...
who I think it is?
Wooooah, this guy here. But is that who I think it is?
Is that Knoth?
Hello.
I know we're not alone here.
I'm aware of that.
Alright, okay! I'm trusting ya!
Nope, okay, I know where we're going!
*little girl and Markiplier mutual screaming*
OHHH NO
OH NO NO
NO NO NO NO
What are you doing --
What are you doing -- WHOA!  OWOAWOAWOAWHOA!!
WOO!!
WOO WOOWOO
WOOWOOWOOWOO
Where do I go?  Where do I go? What do I do?
MMMHHHM
This way?
yes no maybe-so?
I don't know.
Okay.  I guess we're alright.
Why did we make a
Why did we make aDOH NO!!
Oh, hello!
What was THAT?
Ohhhh no.
Oh no.
Ah, good, back in the river of blood!
Oh good, still raining!  Is it still raining?
Mmmm, delightful!
What did I just come out of?
Wot?
You wot mate?
YOUUUU WOT MATE?
Awright.
hello.
Well I guess we gotta carry on.
What is that?
How'd they rip that off the top of that son of a bitch.
Okay, well I guess this is the only way to go.
Through here.
*Breaking Sounds*
Oh-kay, I didn't know what happened there, so I
wasn't sure if that was my fault or something I needed to
worry about, so thank you for clarifying that for me!
Frick you, also.  Frick you.
I'm expecting someone to pop around the corner and just yell,
"Darling!"
Frick all y'all.
I'm gonna have to hide here, aren't I?
I'm gonna ha --
*bad noises*
I'M GONNA HIDE, I'M GONNA HIDE!
Oh god, what was that?
What was that?
OKAY.
But I'm not stupid, am I?
I heard something GROWLING,
and then stip-step-stomp towards me!
Which usually means that something's about to kill me.
As far as I know.
And this seems like a dungeony-type place
where maybe I'm gonna --
*crunching noise*
-- face off.
to the death.
With a baddie.
Yeaaaah.
Kinda seems that way.
Ah good, chapter twelve!  Good thing I'm reading these out of order.
*fire and brimstone preacher voice*
Okay, there was a bunch of logical fallacies in that one
and then I heard a creaking board which usually means
that something is creepy-crawling...
...up...
...upon me.
*50% growl, 50% sigh*
I don't like that.
Why?  Why are you doing this to me?
*sigh*  I KNOW when I'm being dicked with, okay?
I KNOW when I'm being dicked with, OKAY?
You are OBVIOUSLY messing with me.
Ah, why yes.  Ah.
It was leading me here.
HIIIIIIIIII
Euyyeyyyeyyyey, what are you doing?!
Huh? NICE DICK. Okay.
Why are you just -- uuooh, okay.
Alright then. I'm gonna go THIS way then.
So uh, you're gonna be creepy-crawling after me?
Hoohhkay, I'm gonna go in here now.
HUHHpy doopy doo. Boink.
You gonna come after me? Huh? Do you know even where I am?
Do you have any idea
ANY idea
who you're messin' with, HUH? You think you know,
about ME?
and what I've been through?
I've been through more horror situations than
you can even possibly IMAGINE!
So what makes YOU think YOU can
beat ME, hiding in this closet? I don't think so.
I think a whole lot of none of that. That's what I think.
So how 'bout you turn around, uhhh....
....go fuck yourself.
No. No, not in there. Heh.
Can you--?
FUCKIN' YOU.
FUCKIN' YOU!
Yeah, that's right.
Be like Chris Trager from the first game
aaaaand get the wrong locker!
That's right.  That's right.
Ugh, it's still squishy though.
What's so squishy?
No-no-no!
*world's biggest collection of Markiplier 'no's*
What's that sound?
*neighboring locker opens*
*SILENT TERROR*
*another neighboring locker opens*
I'm gonna go for it!
MMMBAAAAAAI BABY BYE!
BYE (X6), SLIDEY!
Okay, yes!  Oh, NAILED IT!
Nailed it to the wall!  The door is, I --
I didn't mean to do that.
Okay, whatever, I did it anyway because I'm a BOSS.
I'm a badass.  I'm a boss.  I'm a baller.
I'm a shot-caller -- I went the wrong way.  Oh, fuck.
It's a dead end.  I'm dead now.  Oh, oh wait!  Over here!
I should have known that!  I'm stupid!
Okay.
EEEEEEEEE, alright that's not good.
Thaaaaat's not good!
Eeee-yoopty!  Alright.
Alright.  And we're good.
And we're clear!
And everything's good, I'm an expert at this!
And they're all dumb and HE'S RIGHT BEHIND ME!
*world's biggest collection of Markiplier 'oh boy's*
Ay yi yi (x3)
Ahhh, this guy doesn't know what he's doing.
Uhokay, I don't know what that was about.
Is this whole place falling?!
Is it just me or is this whole place falling?
Whole place falling?!
Oh, hi.  YOOPTY one more time!
Alrighty then!
EURGH
Man, I can't believe this guy isn't like, the Olympic-level runner
that the first Outlast guy was.  YEAH!
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
What do you think of that?  "Ohhh, oh nooo!"
"Youuu!  I'm gonna getchuuu!"
"HWOEEEYOY!"
"Why, you!"
Man, maybe tucked your stomach in, you might be able to get --
*smashing noises*
-- oh, that guy's getting through that!
Oh shit, what do I do?
Where do I go? (x2)  What do I do? (x2)  I wasted time!
OH!!
AAAH, NO!  I WASN'T READY!!
I didn't mean to do that!  Whyyy?!
Get out the window!!  (x3)
*facepalm*
I didn't know that I had to -- I was gloating.
I was gloating when I should have been winning.
I was gloating when I should've been winning!
I was gloating when I should've been winning.
THAT'S what I did there. Okay. I did that wrong. Okay.
So I need to push that thing outta the way, because I did not see that.
Yeah, honestly just didn't see it. Didn't see it.
Boosh, boosh, boosh, boosh,
boosh, boosh boosh and probably good enough!
WheeeeeeeBOOSKIE!
Wheee!  Ow.
wait whut
Okay...so I'm here now.
Ah!
Reality needs to fix itself because I am NOT doing okay.
I am a hundred percent not doing okay.
Okay, and I don't know what was going on with that window, but it seemed
seemed to have been laughing at me, but hey!
My climbing skills are good, I'll have you know.
Hoppity-hoopty.
Ohhh, shoopty-woopty, why am I in here?
Have I caught everything that I needed?
I don't know man, I don't know.
*giant sigh*  Okay.
But either way, that's all the time that I've got for this episode.
It's been a wild ride on this one, hasn't it?
Oh, raining blood!  Oh, dead fish!  Oh, dead bodies!  Ooh, dead people trying to kill me, so
thanks everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see YOU...
...in the next video!
Bye-bye!!
*horror game outro music*